People always wanna drag-and-drop files directly from their desktop into Web applications.
With Wave, you can!
Watch as Stephanie creates a new Wave...
...and then, drag-and-drops a bunch of photos from iPhoto directly into Wave.
Thumbnails will appear on my machine as soon as they start uploading on hers.
I can then drag-and-drop photos from my machine directly into the Wave as well.
You can see at the bottom of the screen there's an images menu.
This menu allows you to operate on all of the images in the Wave...
...not just the images you added.
This is an easy and convenient way to make a collaborative photo album using Wave.
Now that we have a Wave, with lots of images in it,...
...we wanna share it with our friends.
Drag our friend, "Bloggy" onto the Wave.
This will publish the Wave on Steph's blog.
Embedding is an easy way to put Waves directly into any website.
Much the same way you can do with Maps today.
Watch as I go to Steph's blog.
You can see on Steph's blog that we embed the whole Wave, not just the images.
This includes all of the UI.
Watch as I leave a comment.
Everything that I type on the blog immediately appears in Steph's Wave client.
Steph can respond in her Wave client and her typing immediately appears on the blog.
Since I contributed to the blog, the Wave will also show up in my Wave client,...
...and we can continue the conversation from there.
Embedding Waves is good for developers...
...because it allows them to drop a rich, collaborative UI...
...into websites with very little code.
It's great for users because it allows them to have a consistent UI...
...as well as every conversations they care about all in one place.